you've got a what is it a star on the
Bronx I did congratulations a star on
the Bronx yeah did you get a street sign
- one day I did I do have a street sign
yeah yeah yeah well like it was I was
one of four people the time was myself
Chas momentary Irene Cara yep and the
the doobage dreads from TMZ okay yeah um
the dark with dreads yeah is that what
it says on the street screen
take a left on dude with dreads yeah so
I was wondering four people inducted
that day and they had my sign like right
in the corner of one of the major
intersection sections in the Bronx right
up the street from Yankee Stadium 161st
Street in Grand Concourse my sign was
right on that corner and like I mean I
grew up there and so many you know
moments of my life I could stand on that
corner and point to almost drown in a
pool over there I used to run track over
there I lost my virginity across the
street from the street sign you were
inside why are we applauding wait so
okay I mean yay but that are said it's
across the street from the street song
yeah yeah okay was a long time ago with
nothing no no I know I'm okay it's just
weird that you're looking like yesterday
yeah it's just such a momentous event in
your life and now there's a street sign
there
it's matter what I've thought that I
would begin street sign across the
street from where that incident happened
yeah no the incident I mean just the
thing whatever whatever anyway no I want
to stay on this topic for as long as
time give me the signal to move on and
I'm like no we're staying right here
let's talk about your that's not much
sure its water here no no that's just
water that's fine you can have that
don't don't touch Andy's or you can have
mine it's embalming fluid yeah keep some
looking for
you